[MUSIC PLAYING]
BHARATH LINGAM: [x]cube LABS
is a unique organization.
And we provide digital strategy
and then help enterprises
so that they can see a
good future for themselves
for the next few years.
And we also complement it with
very strong execution skills.
SAPTARSHI ROY CHAUDHURY: We
have this philosophy where we
call ourselves digital natives.
And one of the key traits
of being a digital native
is to keep updating
yourself, upgrading yourself
on the newest of technology
that's coming into the market.
BHASKAR MEDHI: What truly
defines [x]cube LABS is
our ability to bring all
the technology components,
all the skill sets
that are needed,
to solve a problem
for our client.
SAPTARSHI ROY CHAUDHURY:
Our work culture
is one of our biggest assets.
While we are extremely
serious about having fun,
you will always find
some of our programmers
hack late into the night.
And definitely make sure
they're going and running
the Hyderabad marathon as well.
These are some of the cultures
that we have very, very close
to our heart.
BHASKAR MEDHI: The
reason we decided
to join the Google
Agency program
primarily is to
help our clients.
We have a responsibility
to make sure
that our clients have access
to the best of technologies,
access to the best of tools,
to solve their problems.
SAPTARSHI ROY
CHAUDHURY: So our team
attended a lot of industry
events and academic events
that Google conducted
for its agency partners.
We learned about BWA and AMP
through a few such events.
And we actually implemented BWA
for a very challenging project
with one of the leading
food retailers in India.
What excites me about BWA is
that it really breaks down
the native barrier.
And it brings in all
the native benefits
on a web-based interface.
At the same time,
it brings together
native features, like setting
onto your home screen,
popping up a push notification,
and offline access,
which is really awesome.
BHARATH LINGAM: I think
the Google Developer Agency
program is a
wonderful opportunity
to increase the collaboration
between some of the smartest
technology minds and Google, as
well as provide them feedback
on what are some of the
things that we would want
as a development group,
three months, six
months down the line.
SAPTARSHI ROY CHAUDHURY:
It's a matter of pride
that when we do a project
and when we design it well,
our customers, the end
users, they love it.
And that's probably the biggest
satisfaction that you can have.
Going to the market
with the validation
that we are one of the first
few Google certified agencies
not only helps you
learn new technologies.
It also motivates us
to keep delivering
to a certain standard.
[MUSIC PLAYING]